the new thing
seems to be fat shaming people who have
abandoned the Trump cult
last week I played a video for you which
we'll review later of Donald Trump going
after William Barr who is still a
right-wing nut I mean William Barr is
still a right-wing nut but William Barr
has said
um you know these this classified
document stuff is crazy and Trump didn't
win the election yeah Will William Barr
has stated some factual things uh Trump
said all he wanted to do is eat so the
next one is that now Trump is fat
shaming Chris Christie now Chris
Christie is obese that's absolutely true
but so is Donald Trump and so there's a
couple different factors to this and
we're going to talk about that in a
moment
um Donald Trump this is Yahoo news uh
actually a Business Insider it seems
Donald Trump shares fat shaming photo of
Chris Christie on Truth social following
critical Mar-A-Lago interview
Donald Trump shared a photo on Truth
social of a large man leaning over a
buffet counter he captioned the post
Chris Christie at a Roy Rogers at 11 PM
in the evening trying to console himself
Trump has been accused of fat-shaming
Christy after Christy gave a critical
ABC news interview
now we don't know who the man in the
picture is take a look at this picture
just so if you're watching
it really does look like Chris Christie
and I've been in a room this is so it
sounds like I'm I'm
joking but I've been in a room that had
a food
station with Chris Christie when we were
both at politicon and behind the scenes
they had a whole food thing for us
it does look like Chris Christie I mean
I don't know whether it's Chris Christie
or not but Donald Trump posting Chris
Christie at a Roy Rogers at 11 p.m in
the evening trying to console himself uh
and of course he is just attacking Chris
Christie for being obese here is the
clip I mentioned of him going after
William Barr because Barr is overweight
[Music]
ships that we have these weak students
attorney generals that don't know how to
do their jobs
all he wanted to do was eat so there's a
couple things here number one the
criticisms of the people that have
abandoned Trump have to be like this
because even though they're still people
I don't agree with you know John Bolton
William Barr Chris Christie and some of
them haven't even really abandoned Trump
some of them have just said I like Trump
but he's wrong about this one thing
their criticisms of trump are completely
substantive in almost all cases and so
it's not like Trump can come back at
them with anything substantive because
he would just be lying which he has no
problem doing but it would sort of be
very obvious so instead he has to go to
this type of stuff oh he's fat he's
having this different type of thing
that's one part of it that he's focusing
on this because there's really no
substantive response to the things that
these folks are saying the other part of
it is that Trump is obese
and so Trump making fun or attacking
others because they are overweight is
also weird and and you know I I don't
know that I need to give you these
numbers necessarily but just to kind of
like check my math
Trump claims to be six foot three and
two thirty nine now that would put him
like us right on the edge of being obese
according to BMI now BMI is not a
perfect metric we know that if you're a
bodybuilder
a BMI will say you're obese and that's
not relevant or accurate in any kind of
operational sense but for a lot of
people it gives us kind of an idea now I
don't believe Trump 6-3 and I don't
believe Trump is 239 and most people
don't we know Trump's not six three
because Barack Obama is six two and Tom
Brady is 6'4 and when Trump's next to
Brady even wearing what we it's pretty
widely known Trump wears lifts wearing
whatever shoes Trump wears he's notably
shorter than Tom Brady notice so he's
nowhere near six three Brady six four
and he seems to be about the same height
or slightly shorter than Barack Obama so
when you know that and you say well
Trump is conservative Trump has to weigh
at least 255. he might weigh 265. if
Trump is six two or six one and weighs
255 or 265 it's all obese it's all
obesity so do I care that Trump's obese
no Trump doesn't exercise and eats a
terrible diet it's kind of not shocking
but he's going after people a lot
because they are obese or overweight
when he himself is of course as well so
this is another you know what are the
principles that we continue to see
um Republicans claim to have one set of
principles and abandon them when it's
inconvenient
uh Trump uh Trump and other Republicans
they love to make allegations which we
later learned were actually almost like
confessions of the things they were
doing or the things that they planned to
do themselves voter fraud uh trying to
steal an election they didn't win is of
course at the top of the list and um
also
uh claiming that they are about policy
and substance and whatever else and then
fat shaming their political opponents
when they can't come up with anything
substantive to say so their principles
actually don't matter they only care
about their principles when they are
convenient